[Musique]
je crois que
du point de vue
politique en afrique on a eu des hauts
et des bas en matière de parité il y à
des pays qui se sont distingués pendant
que d'autres ont eu des difficultés
ces pays qui se sont distingués ont pu
dans le processus démocratique interne
ouvrir des voies à la gente féminine en
terme de participation alors que des
pays comme le libéria et est
doté de l'afrique de l'est ont eu un peu
plus de difficultés parce que justement
les femmes n'ont pas pu à pénétrer à
l'effet les barrières à l'entrée de la
chose politique et ses barrières peuvent
être social ces barrières peuvent être
économiques parce que pour faire de la
politique il faut beaucoup d'argent et
ses barrières peuvent être aussi en
termes de perception du rôle
traditionnel de la femme dans la dans la
société et le bilan est mitigé nous
avons depuis jean et depuis maputo en
termes de conventions à pour la
participation de la femme dans la chose
politique connue grosso modo une avancée
de quelque chose dans les 3 % dans
des zones de 20 à 30% pour la plupart
des pays une autre chose aussi c'est que
du point de vue normatif on a vu des
communautés comme la communauté de
l'afrique de l'ouest la communauté
d'afrique de l'est établir des normes a
même si certains pays n'arrive pas à
suivre ces normes on sait au moins que
les membres existe et quand on est en
dessous on le sait quand on est déçu on
le sait à ce qu'ils aient représente une
certaine avancée dans le bilan on va
dire il est vraiment 10g
il ya un facteur important qui a été à
la base des avancées à ce facteur
a profité de l'environnement des des
espaces vous avez des particularités
comme le rwanda on sait qu'il ya eu un
génocide et que après ce génocide qui a
connu beaucoup de morts dont beaucoup
sont des hommes il y a eu un rôle
beaucoup plus avancé de la femme dans la
société traditionnelle
beaucoup de femmes sont devenues des
chefs de famille et on a su que ces
chefs de familles femmes ont produit des
résultats assez intéressant en termes de
gouvernance de la maison et donc on
s'est dit si les femmes plus donc opérer
cette avancée au niveau domestique
donc au niveau de la communauté et donc
par ricochet au niveau de la nation
d'autres cas sont des cadres leadership
au sénégal par exemple on a un président
le président wade de son temps qui a
montré un leadership personnel dans
l'avancée des femmes on sait par exemple
dans ce temps-là au sénégal on avait
l'assemblée avait deux chambres la
chambre basse et la chambre haute et la
chambre basse avec une quelque chose
comme
même pas 30 % 10 % alors que le
président wade avait des nominations au
niveau de la sambre autres et il a nommé
près de 65 à 70 % de femmes dans la
chambre haute et ça a donné le déclic et
ça ce déclic a été à la base de la vie
du vote de la loi sur la parité au
sénégal et donc ça m'amène au deuxième
problème qui est aux deux jours au
deuxième facteur qui est les mesures
affirmative à au bénéfice des femmes
beaucoup de ces pays ont adopté ce que
la crise appelle temporaire mais j'ose
qui permettent de sauter de comptes de
quotas pour les femmes et est donc ces
quotas ont boosté la participation des
femmes dans
les processus électoraux et ses quotas
n'étaient pas seulement des quotas au
niveau national dans certains pays comme
le niger on a des quotas au niveau même
des partis politiques qui sont des
quotas volonté est dictée par les
parties grosso modo
réserver des sièges aux femmes
établis des
quotas pour la participation des femmes
ont été des facteurs très très
déterminant dans dans la participation
des femmes et aussi le rôle des femmes
leaders lorsqu'on a vu des femmes élues
au niveau local des femmes élues au
niveau de l'assemblée nationale pour ses
des politiques sociales assez avancé ça
donne l'exemple et ça donne l'exemple
aussi à d'autres politiciennes qui
hésitent à se lancer à pouvoir faire le
pas et tous ces facteurs réunis ont été
à la base de ces avancées que nous avons
noté dans les pays que vous avez cités
vous faites bien de mentionner l'exemple
de l'ethiopie on peut également citer
l'exemple de l'ouganda qui après avoir
eu des années à
une présidente de l'assemblée nationale
est aujourd'hui le l'ouganda se faire
remarquer par une premier ministre
femme est pas une vice-présidente femmes
et donc il y a des émules qui peuvent
être créées par ces exemples
l'ethiopie en tout cas très intéressant
en dehors du conflit qui se développent
ces derniers temps les kills et
l'ethiopie a connu une croissance assez
remarquable les dix quinze dernières
années et ce qui montre un éveil un peu
de la façon de penser et du rôle de
femme en économie aussi la météo qui est
donc le cas de l'ouganda et est
imbattable on a eu aussi d'autres cas en
dehors des cas de libéria et qui
aujourd'hui la tanzanie art
une présidente qui était vice-présidente
avant le bébé à une vice présidente donc
ce sont des cas qui se ski surf sur les
résultats que les femmes ont en matière
de politique on sait que le social est
très important à la jeunesse pour la
jeunesse en afrique aujourd'hui et la
jeunesse de plus en plus sur un contre
que les femmes portent les politiques
sociales plus plus renforcée et que à
partir de ce moment là on ne peut faire
confiance aux femmes maintenant
évidemment les pays qui ont réussi ont
aussi aidé à enlever les pesanteurs qui
empêchent les femmes d'évoluer et ces
femmes le travail non payé d'effarement
le travail domestique des femmes et la
perception négative que les femmes dont
les femmes jouissent ou du moins souffre
en matière de participation à la chose
politique donc il ya un certain nombre
de facteurs qui se conjuguent et qui
font d'abord et clore ses possibilités
et lorsque nous avons cette possibilité
il ya des conséquences en matière
d'impact sur la vie de la population est
qui et qui justifie que on est en droit
d attendre à la continuation de cet élan
de confiance dont les femmes lui au
niveau de la chose politique
bon il faut dire que vous voyez par
exemple les nations unies ont édicté
comme principe de ne laisser personne
pour compte et aussi de commencer par
ceux qui sont le plus vulnérables a en
premier et donc lorsque vous regardez la
chaîne politique les femmes se trouvent
à la base elles sont ce que beaucoup de
personnes appellent cyniquement le
bétail électoral elle constitue la
mobilisation de tous les partis
politiques elles investissent énormément
dans la chose politique mais lorsqu'il
s'agit d'établir les nominations
lorsqu'il s'agit d'établir les listes
électorales elles sont laissées de côté
donc lorsque les femmes sont de plus en
plus prises en compte dans les chics et
politique ça traduit généralement un
éveil pour compte des consciences un
éveil politique qui bénéficie à la
population de manière générale
deuxièmement la croissance économique
des pays africains doit se focaliser
d'abord sur les zones en de plus faible
productivité et les zones de plus faire
pour d'activité c'est la zone informel
et la zone rurale donc le secteur
informel qui bénéficient pas assez
politique d'investissement de l'état
vont donc bénéficier beaucoup plus de
l'attention des gouvernants lorsque ce
sont les femmes qui participent aux
prises de décision donc ça c'est déjà un
premier impact du point de vue
économique
maintenant du point de vue social il a
été démontré et voulait aller voir par
exemple les
la réponse au vide dans tous les pays la
plupart des pays où il y avait des
femmes aux commandes on a vu que la
réponse a été beaucoup plus immédiate
elle était beaucoup plus conséquente
elle a été beaucoup que social
donc de ce point de vue on peut dire que
la participation des femmes à un impact
non seulement économique mais a un
impact aussi sociale non du point de vue
purement politique
on a vu que
la gouvernance politique elle-même
joué deux sets en fluidité lorsque les
femmes sont aux affaires il y a beaucoup
moins de conflits il ya beaucoup moins
de tiraillements lorsque les femmes sont
aux affaires et on a vu par exemple au
sénégal
en tête de d effectivité ou du moins si
d efficacité de l'exercice parlementaire
lorsque vous voyez les femmes le
aptitudes que vous comparez aux
aptitudes des hommes qui sont re
parlement on a vu que l'aco asseman de
la compétence chez les femmes étaient
presque doublé de l'accroissement de la
compétence chez les hommes avant et
après la loi sur la parité ça veut dire
que
l'état dans une certaine mesure gaye i
am effectivité l'administration publique
qu'il faut étendre les la participation
des femmes au pouvoir aux prises de
décisions non pas seulement au niveau
des élections mais aussi au niveau des
nominations et donc l'administration
publique qui jouit d'un plus grand
nombre de femmes aux prises de décision
n'est ce pas devient beaucoup plus
efficace donc c'est sur la base de sa
que l'union africaine la cedeao le sadek
et les autres communautés ont commencé
par édicter des normes pour pouvoir
promouvoir la participation des femmes à
la gouvernance
il faut regarder toit à quatre faisceaux
d'action conjuguer
la première c'est éliminer dans le
corpus législatif le corpus
administratif et procédurier des la
gouvernance en afrique éliminer toutes
les barrières qui peuvent empêcher les
femmes des bergers
deuxièmement il faudrait un supporter
les positions électorales pour
comprendre et soutenir les femmes dans
leur envie de participer à la chose
publique
troisièmement il faudrait renforcer les
capacités des femmes à pouvoir
premièrement comprendre deuxièmement
influencé et 3e en bénéficier des
processus et les trolls et les taux pour
le moment ce n'est pas encore le cas
quatrièmement il faudrait éduquer le
public de façon à ce que la perception
du rôle que la femme peut jouer dans la
gouvernance puisse être
maintenue par exemple vous allez dans la
plupart des universités en afrique les
plus fortes notes aux sorties des
universités sont détenus par les femmes
et lorsque les femmes sortent de
l'université
elles sont les dernières à trouver de
l'emploi imaginez un pays qui promeut
deuxième de l'université dans le monde
de l'emploi donc là de plus en plus les
gens comprennent des ministères qu'ils
espèrent par concernés par la chose
féminines commence pas s'y intéresser
parce que c'est porteur de productivité
dans ses actions méritent de façon
conjuguer vont s'ajouter aux actions
législatives que j'avais évité au départ
c'est à dire la fixation des quotas
c'est à dire s'assurer que les lois sur
les quotas ne sont pas assujettis à des
paiements de 2 comme on appelle ça la
loi sur la parité en france par exemple
avait édicté des des
défis commander
des pénalités pour les partis qui
n'auraient pas de disparité alors ses
fenêtres peuvent être utilisées par des
partis politiques qui vont faire des
listes non paritaire et pouvoir payer
des pénalités pour ça je crois que ça a
été corrigé en france et donc le sénégal
a bénéficié de
l'apprentissage
de la loi sur la parité en france pour
faire une loi qui est assez équilibré
qui élimine les listes qui ne sont pas
paritaire et qui aussi exige qu'il y ait
des ce qu'on appelle les listes des
briques les zébrés ses listes dans
lequel on aimerait alternative sommes
enfin hommes-femmes au lieu de mettre
les hommes de van et les femmes en
arrière alors pensé qu'on n'aura jamais
assez de postes pour vous voir même
atteindre la première femme donc ce sont
selon moi les actions qu'on pourrait
mener en dehors de la le renforcement du
pouvoir économique des femmes 1 parce
que nous ne sommes pas dupes les femmes
ne peut pas faire de la politique sans
argent alors que les hommes font de la
politique avec de l'argent toute
personne dans n'importe quel pays qui
veut se lancer dans la politique doit
avoir des ressources financières dont
renforcer le pouvoir économique des
femmes est aussi une façon de les aider
à pouvoir participer à la politique en
dehors de ça où les femmes et les autres
organisations a appuyé le gouvernement à
pouvoir asseoir le cadre législatif va
pouvoir asseoir le cadre natif dont les
pays ont besoin pour concevoir la
participation des femmes dans la chose
politique de façon beaucoup plus
ordonnée